foreign
comes from Mike in Delaware Mike writes
I have extremely loving and gracious
parents oh boy
my parents are offering to upgrade my
roof but I'm afraid of the strings that
may come with it later in my life why is
Mike why is Mike the reason for my
hesitation is my mother's loose tongue
wow she makes snide comments from time
to time which makes me not want her
assistance I don't need a new roof yet
but recognize I am very fortunate to
have parents that are are in a position
to help me how should I go about this
should I accept a gift or keep my
nobility and save up for next summer
when I can pay for a roof on my own
I don't think taking a gift from your
parents is has anything to do with
nobility
I think that is your way of talking
yourself of giving yourself permission
to not be in business with your parents
and when you take money from them you
are in business with your parents and
your mom sounds like she
um
pays a fee
for permission to speak into your life
and you get to no longer do business
with her I would not George I wouldn't
take this money I would say hey thanks
nope I'm grown up I bought my own house
I'm gonna save up and pay for my own
roof by the way I don't even need one
right now you don't have to be ugly
about it you don't have to be rude about
it
um but you know you've dealt this your
whole life Mike your whole life you've
dealt with this Mom helps you out with
something and then she just has to
berate you about it man at some point
yeah I'm growing up I'm not taking their
money anymore I'm still gonna love them
still gonna go to lunch with them on
Sundays that's great I'm just not taking
your money anymore yeah I would listen
to that hesitation that you have that's
your gut that is wisdom and I think this
is just pure resentment down the road
one way or the other if you do take this
thing because you already uh are you're
not the spirit of this doesn't feel
right to you and I'm gonna listen to
that and say you know what I'm gonna get
myself in a position where I have the
money in the bank to cover the roof I'm
gonna say Mom Dad love you guys thank
you so much for offering uh but I got
this one and there's something symbolic
I mean
maybe fixing the carpet or air
conditioner or something there's
something about the roof because there's
just always that line well I'm putting
still putting a roof over your head and
there's just something about that
they're literally putting a roof over
your head as an adult that gives me that
gives me the indigestions and the gases
not quite the hemorrhoids but it gives
me the gas and I I just like pay for it
yourself man pay for yourself I don't
want the strings attached I'm no puppet
yep all right thanks for the question
Mike it's a good one a lot especially
with all the boundary issues happening
around the holidays Now's the Time to
stand your ground and say no and do it
lovingly but do it firmly